aujourd'hui si on anniversaire et s'est
inversée un petit peu spéciale puisque
j'ai 30 ans les dix dernières années de
ma vie j'ai beaucoup appris j'ai
beaucoup appris sur moi sur les autres
sur la vie sur ce qu'on peut attendre
d'elle aussi ce qu'elle attend de nous
alors pour se voir un petit peu spécial
j'ai décidé de faire une vidéo spéciale
elle aussi puisque je vais vous dire
tout ce que j'aurais aimé qu'on me dise
et que parfois on m'a dit d'ailleurs à
20 ans c'est une liste très personnelle
mais je suis sûr qu elle résonnera chez
certains et certaines d'entre vous saint
paul disait le corps est le temple de
l'esprit et ce temple on en a qu'un à
vous parle de corps on s'attend à ce que
je vous raconte un truc un peu spirituel
ou je ne sais quoi ou une fable je vous
parlais de warren buffett
le troisième homme le plus riche du
monde warren buffett nous invite à
imaginer qu'on nous offre une voiture la
voiture de notre choix avec toutes les
options etc ok ça peut être une voiture
de dames
d'accord mais il ya une contrepartie
c'est que cette voiture c'est celle
qu'on va avoir jusqu'à la fin de notre
vie on aura qu'une seule voiture ssl
donc si on faisait cette expérience de
pensée
la plupart d'entre nous dès que la
voiture elle avait un petit problème
alors déjà avant même de l'utiliser on
aurait lu le manuel
plus d'une fois on aurait bien fait
attention leurs amis au garage et dès
qu'il y avait un petit problème au
niveau du moteur huiles de moteur j'en
sais rien je suis absolument 0 en
voiture ok je serai le garage direct et
c'est parce qu'en fait il y en a qu'une
seule c'est notre voiture et on est
censé l'avoir jusqu'à la fin donc elle
n'a pas intérêt à lâcher et bien pouvoir
n 2 fait ce lien qu'on a avec la voiture
c'est le même lien qu'on a avec notre
corps et notre esprit je mettrais
quelques réserves parce que on choisit
la voiture ce qui n'est pas forcément le
cas du corps de l'esprit excédents mais
malgré ça je vois ce qui veut dire et
c'est vrai que je me rendais pas
forcément content quand j'avais 20 ans
mais voilà on n'a qu'un seul corps il ya
certaines choses on se dit bon ça va oui
ça me fait un petit peu mal mais je
laisse passer
sa part ça vient c'est ok et c est en
fait ça s'empire avec le temps il ya
plein d'examens médicaux qu'on fait pas
forcément parce que on se dit je suis
jeune ça va aller on sent bien et puisse
voilà ça peut s'empirer ça peut
s'empirer est en fait en fait ça peut
devenir ensuite grave est en fait il ya
plein de choses qui vont se faire là
pendant ces dix années l'un de 20 à 30
et qui vont avoir des répercussions
potentiellement sur toutes vos devis des
trucs bêtes par exemple la posture au
niveau du dos et vous esquinté le dos
parce que en fait vous allez passer des
heures et des heures malassis un bref
plein de petits trucs ne négligez pas
les ennuis médecin l'a rendu chez le
dentiste
les examens médicaux peut-être même les
thérapies aussi les soins de peau bref
tout un tas de choses qu'on néglige sur
cette période et qu'à mon sens on
devrait peut-être pas ou en tout cas d'
parfois on regrette de les avoir négligé
la souffrance fait partie de la vie
c'est un concept qu'on voit souvent chez
les bouddhistes et qu'ils appellent
doura c'est une des trois
caractéristiques de l'existence elle dit
que en fait aucun phénomène ne peut nous
satisfaire de manière ultime et
définitive la souffrance fait partie de
la vie elle est inévitable et stoïciens
on parle aussi d'ailleurs et la question
ce n'est pas de savoir quand est-ce
qu'elle va rêver la question c'est de
savoir si lorsqu'elle va arriver je
serai prêt à l'accueillir accepte cette
souffrance et tu seras plus on n'essaie
pas de l'éviter ça sert à rien la
souffrance fait partie de la vie fait le
fou
chacun a sa propre définition de foufou
et ses propres limites mais justement
s'il ya un moment où tu peux tester ses
limites et jouer un peu avec elle c'est
bien la vingtaine
évidemment tu pourras faire le fou aussi
après mais un pas se mentir la vingtaine
c'est un très bon moment pour ça
renforce et nouent des amitiés
d'une manière générale je ressens que la
dizaine tu la passe avec ta famille la
vingtaine tu la passe avec tes amis et
la trentaine tu la passe en train de
construire sa nouvelle famille et à la
quarantaine tu t'occupes de ces familles
etc
bon bref a évidemment il n'y a aucun
impératif là dedans chacun ses choix de
vie il y en a pas un qui soit plus
mauvais qu'un autre
voilà je vous partage juste les miens et
ma vision est ce que je rencontre le
plus souvent aussi quand j'en discute
autour de moi pas et bref partant de ce
constat en fait la vingtaine c'est
vraiment là où
on peut passer le plus de temps possible
avec ses amis et donc renforcer l'amitié
et nouer de nouvelles amitiés qui vont
ensuite resté le plus longtemps possible
dans le temps on se fait aussi des amis
plus tard on nous aussi de l'amitié plus
tard mais je trouve ça forcément moins
évident que je sais pas par exemple
quand tu es en internat avec des potes
ou par exemple les grandes vacances où
pendant deux mois
tes potes et toi vous avez du temps par
exemple essayé de partir en voyage avec
tes amis essaient de construire des
projets avec tes amis enfin voilà mais
tu sais et c'est vraiment de faire ça
c'est important
et profite aussi de ce moment pour
t'éloigner des gens qui peuvent te
paraître nocifs écrit chaque décision
importante que tu prends et pourquoi tu
la prends une des peurs du futur c'est
la peur du regret est-ce que j'ai bien
fait de prendre telle ou telle décision
je pense avoir trouvé une forme de
parade à ça c'est pas une parade
parfaite mais elle marche assez bien
pour que je vous en parle en tout cas à
redire il faut comprendre pourquoi on
regrette on regrette parce qu'en fait on
regarde rétrospectivement une décision
qu'on a prise avec bah je sais pas notre
nous d'aujourd'hui en fait notre
contexte d'aujourd'hui voilà tout ça
fait que on a plus de chance de
regretter mais pourtant quand on a pris
la décision
on l'a pris pour une raison ça compte
pas on n'est pas tombé tu vois la
plupart du temps parfois on fait des
choses totalement idiote et on peut s'en
vouloir mais la plupart du temps et à
vraiment y'a peut expliquer notre
décision
sauf que ce contexte on le perd avec le
temps donc c'est très important de quand
on prend une décision où on risque de la
regretter eh bien on note
pourquoi on la prend qu'est ce qu'on
ressent c'est quoi elle est ressentie
c'est quoi le contexte qu'est ce qui
fait que je je prends cette décision et
pas une autre
et ça le fait que ce soit écrit et que
ce soit accessible plus tard dans le
futur il ya quand même beaucoup moins de
chance de regretter sa décision
en relisant on a le contexte le vrai
contexte on comprend la décision est
donc on la regrette pas prenez le temps
de le faire
c'est important et si jamais vous ne le
faites pas tant pis pas souci faites
vous confiance
si vous l'avez fait un moment c'est qu'à
une bonne raison voilà c'est ma petite
méthode si jamais vous l'utilisez où il
appelait la méthode cyrus
l'ours comme ça j'ai donné mon nom à un
truc voilà je me dis que j'ai quasiment
30 enfin j'ai 30 ans j'ai vraiment du
mal à le comprendre quoi j'ai 30 ans
voilà il est temps de donner son nom à
quelque chose quand même
donc ça c'est la méthode cyrus north ok
pour les résolutions de regrets rendez
moins célèbres il n'y a pas de règles
aux relations amoureuses
il y en a certains ils disent qu'il faut
profiter de la vingtaine pour avoir
différentes expériences etc
d'autres qui disent que pas justement il
faut profiter de ce temps pour essayer
trouver la bonne personne je pense que
si un truc dans lequel n'y a pas de
règle ses rangs les relations amoureuses
et que chacun s'épanouisse de manière
différente donc je vais pas vous enfin
je veux pas me parce que c'est un truc
que je me dis à moi même au final c'est
ça le principe je veux me donner un
conseil là dessus vis ton expérience il
n'y a pas de bonne manière de le faire
et si tu tu as aussi ça la règle d'avant
d'inventer serein ne dépense pas tête
une dent de la merde parce que ton
niveau de vie va sûrement augmenter et
il ya de très grandes chances que entre
la vingtaine et la trentaine ton niveau
de vie va augmenter ses tapas job tu
risque de trouver un job
si dans un job tu risques d'être
augmentée et cetera et cetera
je touche du bois ainsi tous si tout se
passe bien et donc des choses qui me
semblait hors de prix à 20 ans me semble
accessible aujourd'hui à 30 ans par
contre ce que j'ai plus c'est le temps
moi j'ai plus autant de temps que
j'avais à 20 ans donc mon conseil c'est
investi son argent dans des expériences
des voyages des trucs comme ça
personnellement
je re luquet les statuettes les trucs de
collection des trucs geek et ces machins
voilà ça tu peux les garder dans un coin
tu te fais un tableau à craie l'étudient
voilà quand j'aurai plus d'argent
achèterait tout ça mais on devrait
concentrer sur autre chose
encore une fois c'est mon conseil -
profil de tes cheveux frères choisis tes
habitudes
les habitudes sont extrêmement important
parce qu'elles nous font faire tout un
tas de choses de manière quasi
inconsciente on y passe beaucoup
beaucoup de temps par exemple si vous
avez l'habitude de faire quelque chose
tous les matins pendant une demi heure
et bien sûr une année en cumul ce une
demi heure là en cumul ça fait une
semaine sur l'année c'est énorme c'est
énorme
donc nos habitudes elles peuvent
carrément nous transformer elles peuvent
nous modifiées elles font ce qu on a
donc choisi les avec attention et c'est
le plus possible de ne pas les subir
attention aux smartphones alors j'en ai
parlé plusieurs fois sur cette chaîne
youtube et j'en reparlerai je pense
c'est un magnifique outil qui permet de
faire des choses incroyables mais si tu
passe plusieurs heures dessus par jour
et que tu fais ça pendant des semaines
des mois des années et des années et des
années et en fait ces heurts deviennent
des années donc voilà la question c'est
est ce que on a envie de passer des
années sur son téléphone
il y en a qui pourraient répondre oui
d'autres qui pourraient répondre non ça
rejoint un petit peu le conseil
précédent mais je trouvais ça important
dans le contexte actuel de faire un
focus sur le smartphone donc je rejoins
conseil d'avant qui était ne subit pas
tes habitudes si c'est une décision
c'est une décision
par contre si c'est pas une décision à
faire quelque chose apprend à aimer être
seul
apprendre à aimer être seul quelque part
c'est apprendre à s'aimer soi même et je
trouve ça hyper important dans un monde
qui peut générer beaucoup d'incertitude
et de doute soit à l'aise avec toi m
apprends à te connaître apprend à
t'écouter
voilà c'est quelque chose d'important
parce que c'est quelque chose qui peut
prendre énormément de temps c'est un
vrai travail quoi donc plutôt on
commençait mieux c'est petit ips
financiers investis dès que tu peux si
je prends un compte rémunéré à hauteur
de 2%
ok donc pas un livret a et que je décide
de mettre 100 euros par mois
tous les mois dessus ok
si je commence à 30 ans à 60 ans j'aurai
50 mille euros mais si je commence à 20
ans à 60 ans j'aurais 76 mille euros
tout simplement parce que plus la somme
sur le compte est grande et plus les
intérêts en fait rapporte beaucoup mieux
vaut commencer le plus tôt possible même
si c'est juste un petit peu je ne les ai
pas fait malgré ce que mes parents m'ont
conseillé plusieurs fois et je répète
voilà j'espère que cette vidéo conseil
amont mois de 20 ans vous aura plu
je voulais aussi remercier tous les gens
qui ont fait de ma vingtaine une
décennie formidable extraordinaire j'ai
vraiment c'était incroyable voilà donc
merci beaucoup merci notamment à vous
puisque mine de rien ça fait ça fait
sept ans que je suis là vous proposer du
contenu sur youtube et que vous répondez
présent et c'est un pur plaisir et
j'espère qu'on va continuer encore
longtemps
voilà vous embrasse très très fort très
très fort love peace ciao.fr de vous est
ce que j'ai dit que le conseil le plus
important c'est de s'abonner à ma chaîne
et de lâcher un pouce bleus je puisse
juger dit
[Musique]
m